Thanks for sitting until the end of the video
I've been P...oh crap I've started at the
end again.
Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show I'm your
host Paul aka the guy whos not backwards in
coming forward and tomorrow I'll make the
Tenet Video that you're watching right now.
Since August I've done a tonne of videos on
the movie and I've compiled the most asked
questions to clear up any confusion over the
film.
This includes why the future version of the
Protagonist shot at himself, what the Algorithm
is, why Kat didn't need a mask on the boat
and a lot lot more
If this is your first time here then please
click the thumbs down button and make sure
you unsubscribe from the channel to never
see a video.
With that out the way, thank you for clicking
this, now let's get into the breakdown.
Ok so Tenet opens with an Opera scene that
pretty much throws you into the movie at the
deepend.
But what exactly is going on here?
Well on the surface it seems like The Protagonist
is part of a CIA operation to infiltrate the
Opera during a siege so that he can secure
the algorithm.
This fails and instead he's drafted into the
TENET organisation after being double crossed,
having his teeth pulled out and also choking
down on what he believes is a cyanide pill.
Sounds like my kinda night at the Opera.
But what exactly was going on here, well The
Protagonist was actually given this intel
by the future version of himself and this
was so that he could not only ensure that
he handed the Algorithm over to Sator but
also make it so that he not only met Neil,
but also showed he was willing to lay his
life on the line.
Before the finale we learn from Ives that
the splinter team mission is meant to be one
that nobody returns from.
Ives even says that they can't afford having
anyone left alive who knows what the algorithm
is and the fact that the protagonist takes
the pill shows that he's willing to lay down
everything if needs be.
Now why the future version made sure that
Sator got a piece of the algorithm is hinted
at by Priya who refuses to change telling
his past version about where the algorithm
is.
Do try and keep up.
She says that they actually need Sator to
bring all of the pieces together so that they
can then snatch them and then split them up.
The entire point of the finale is to trick
Sator into believing that his mission in burying
the Algorithm is successful so that his future
version won't change anything and will continue
collecting the pieces in order to bring them
together and carry out the plan that will
allow the algorithm to be stolen.
This is why the Tenet team allow the explosion
to go off so that the past version of the
character believes that his future forces
succeed in completing their mission.
In the car chase we saw how the antagonist
learning the truth about certain events helped
him to play them to his advantage and thus
his past version has to believe that he will
win.
In actuality, the Tenet team now have everything
they need to divide up the algorithm and take
it to their graves.
But what is the algorithm exactly?
Well it's probably the plot point that we
learn the least about but from what we discover
we can piece certain things together.
From Priya we learn that the algorithm was
developed in the future by a scientist that
discovered a way to fully invert the world.
This would allow things like global warming
and climate change to be reversed so that
future generations would not suffer because
of the sins of the past.
The algorithm is pretty much a bomb that when
detonated will cause a massive spike in reverse
radiation across the planet that forces the
past to fold in on itself wiping out all life
beyond the consciousness of the future.
Contrary to the Grandfather clock theory,
the people of the future believe that it is
possible to change things in the past whereas
we learn throughout the film that it's not.
However, because the people of the future
always tried to change things they always
will make the algorithm and attempt to send
it back so we can see the events of the movie
play out.
The Scientist realised that in destroying
the past they would destroy themselves and
thus she seperated the algorithm and buried
it which is where it was found by Sator.
Upon believing he's won Sator says that someday
in the future a man in a tower will flip a
switch and armageddon will be both created
and avoided.
Now the armageddon he is referring to is creating
it in the past in order to avoid it in the
future.
He believes that once the algorithm is planted
and then detonated that all life in the past
will be wiped out.
However, what the Tenet team do is basically
along the same lines as the Scientist and
they seperate the algorithm, invert it and
place it somewhere so that it can never be
found.
By doing this at no point in the future can
these pieces of the algorithm be put together
so they can't be used.
But who is the scientist exactly?
Well the movie tells us very little but as
we only ever meet one scientist and they happen
to be female I believe that this is the same
person that becomes the oppenheimer of her
time.
We learn that Laura has been studying the
reverse radiation for quite some time and
that though the people in the past haven't
figured out how to do it, one day they will.
I think that Laura is actually the person
who discovers the formula for inverting things
and the only time we meet her she says that
she was assigned to the project and has been
studying it.
This close proximity to the time inverted
objects makes her the perfect person to figure
it all out and they we'll never know for definite,
movies tend to give us the answers even if
they don't always point them out.
Because this is the only possible person we
meet who fits the role I think it's the case
and ey...if the shoe fits.
Also I was gonna keep this video really tenet
and actually give the answers before asking
the questions but I thought that would be
too confusing.
Now this idea of everything being pre-determined
has put a lot of people off the movie and
made them say "what's the point."
Well as Neil says before he goes off to his
death, they have faith in the laws of the
universe and by carrying out things the way
they're supposed to it shows that there is
actually a grand plan to it all.
Tenet is a fatalist film and I'm sure many
of us look back on bad things that happened
to us and see that they actually led to a
positive outcome years down the line which
this film seems to also be hinting at.
Now though lots of people die along the way,
that doesn't mean that Tenet doesn't have
somewhat of a happy ending and though we don't
know if The Protagonist goes off with Kat
and Max at the end I think the movie is hinting
to us that he does.
Before going away for the...the last mission
and I swear I'm not crying...you're crying...Neil
asks The Protagonist if he's going back to
London to check in on Kat and he replies by
saying no it's far to dangerous.
Neil then says "not even from afar" which
the Protagonist also denies.
However we know from the finale that he did
go back to London to check in on her from
afar so this was indeed a lie.
Now we've already done a big breakdown on
why we think that Neil is actually Kat's son
Max which will be linked at the end of the
video but I think Neil asked these two specific
questions because he knows that The Protagonist
did indeed meet the pair after killing Priya.
Speaking of there were several questions surrounding
why they didn't just hang around at the turnstile
after she was shot and then revert her there.
However, we do know that before this moment
Sators men owned it and operated there so
this would cause issues with the past had
they hung around.
They're only able to move then and there because
Sator is out on the highway so they have to
travel back to the turnstile that they know
will be accessible at the airport during their
heist.
I've also had a lot of people ask why Kat
didn't need to wear a mask on the boat at
the end.
I'm never sure of exactly what boat they mean
as she's on several in the finale but if it's
the TENET one it's because she's in a sealed
room which has a regular supply of Oxygen
so the mask isn't needed and if it's when
she's on Sators it's because she's reverted
back to normal at this point so isn't feeling
the effects of inversion.
Many of you wondered where Kat went after
the boat scene at the end and the simple answer
is that she hid away whilst her past version
continued on the same path that she did.
All Kat would have to do was lie low until
the inversion scene in which that version
of her goes to the past and then she could
pop out as there is no duplicates and continue
living life like normal, aware that she succeeded
and that her husband doesn't exist beyond
this point.
Outside of the airport the characters are
actually very good at avoiding themselves
and we even see that The Protagonist passes
the windmill that he was in at the start of
the movie, well aware that his past self is
hidden out of view so they won't come face
to face.
Now the next question is why can't anyone
understand what anyone is saying in any of
the movie.
That's because the movie was mixed during
the pandemic on some Iphone headphones and
the score was so good that Nolan told them
to turn it up to 11.
Bass in the ride had the car going like.
Nah but seriously I have seen a lot of people
asking why the Protagonist shot at himself
at the airport.
The first time we see this fight scene it
seems like the attacker is trying to kill
him, however in hindsight we know that this
is actually the future version of the character
who is just trying to make it to the turnstile.
The reason that he fires the gun at his past
self isn't to kill him it's actually to unload
the entire thing so that it can't be used
against him.
From his POV we can clearly see that he knows
it won't hit his head and thus he is deliberately
missing on purpose.
The past version even grabs it from him from
the end of the fight and rather than trying
to snatch it back he dismantles it to make
sure that no matter what he won't be shot.
Speaking of Turnstiles a lot of people are
confused about why people have to see themselves
exiting the turnstile before going into it.
This is simply because if they know they got
out the otherside then they will get out but
I don't think it's completely imperative to
their operation beyond simply knowing that
things will be ok.
Now most of the ops to do with the turnstiles
are led by Ives and many of you have been
asking who he is.
We don't actually know but we do know that
he was hired by TENET in order to basically
be the cavalry for The Protagonist at the
Turnstile and also be the person that leads
the final op.
Ives was clearly very close to The Protagonist
if he was picked to be someone who will guard
the algorithm but beyond that we know very
little.
Now that is the main point of the movie and
it's pretty much said that the Tenet ops should
know very little about each other which is
why we don't actually learn who he is.
I think that's all of the major questions
that I haven't cleared up in my previous videos
but I will be doing one in the coming weeks
which talks about why no one actually dies
in the film.
It's difficult to post that without spoiling
things but I will get to work on it and drop
it after I think enough people have had the
time to see the movie.
Don't forget that on the 30th of December
we're giving away three copies of the Lord
Of The Rings 4k box set to our subscribers.
All you have to do to be in with a chance
of winning is like the video, make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the episode.
The links to our socials are in the description
and you can also support the channel by clicking
the join button and as a thank you, you get
videos like this early.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of Neil's
timeline in the film and also our 100 easter
eggs video which will both be linked on screen
now.
They're some of our best work and that latter
was featured in Men's Health magazine so definitely
check them out after this.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time.
Take care, Peace